what like specifically is identity
politics
so what he's talking about is tribalism
so tribal so there's identity politics
and i i could be butchering i'm not an
expert
this is just my understanding
it's like something that kind of started
in the 70s so it's kind of like
you're
it's like using
politics to like
sorry they're going to roast me in the
comments for this
definition okay you're gonna roast me
for not understanding and he explained
it it's like it's like using politics to
divide people okay so instead of saying
like we're we're americans they'll be
like oh you're you're a white american
you're a black american you're an asian
american does that make sense yeah and
they kind of like use that to like
divide i want to say
but i think what he's talking about
there's a
no i'm butchering that i'm so sorry guys
should we google the definition let's
just yes is an approach wherein people
of a particular gender race
social background social class
environmental or other identifying facts
develop
political agendas based on their
identities
so that the pop oh so it's like the
politics is based on like who you are
okay so and so i think what she he's
talking about tribalism
which is
like the
uh definition
i don't know i'm the wrong person the
state the state of being organized into
tribes so he's saying that the the us
was based on tribalism and and identity
politics is new
okay that's what he's saying okay
but
i don't really have strong opinions on
that because i just i don't think i
understand the definitions well enough
yeah
i would need to look at them a little
bit more just to understand just the
difference between
those two definitions because it they
sound
similar
they say like i'm like okay
what's the what's the difference because
they sound similar to me but um
yeah
i think
go ahead i think like when i think of
identity politics it's kind of like do
you remember when i was arguing at that
table were you there when no i don't
know if you were there when the wnba
player girl was there do you know that
um
no
did you see that clip yes it's kind of
like how as soon as i was arguing
something they bring up that i'm a white
woman
instead of arguing with me about the
like like what we're talking about and
we weren't even talking about race okay
they'll bring up like what like what i
look like rather than like talking about
the argument okay and the politics
that's what i i think of i don't know if
i'm right okay
okay that makes a little bit more sense
yeah
yes okay because because like at that
point we were talking about gender i'm
like what
what does that have to do with anything
and a lot of people
do that okay i it is clicking now that
example makes sense well let's let's
watch a little bit more just to see if
they and i agree with you i find a lot
of students phenomenally irritating but
i would question how much
power they have
in contrast to the things i find more
worrying that happening in the world
today right or even the professors right
even 20 year olds don't have that much
power but they're not 20 forever
10 years later they're 30.
20 years later they're 40. right and
whatever happens in the university
happens everywhere five years later and
very very sadly for people in my
politics left-wing politics what happens
to people as they get older is that
they've traditionally got more
conservative
so i don't think you can make a case
that the the the current where people
they're like we want our money
so like wait they're like half the 20
year old yeah
so it's like what
is so just huge 20 today is actually
going to be the ideology that takes them
all the way through their life that's
never been the case
it'll be around long enough to do plenty
of damage like it already is okay but
even if we accept that students sorry i
know we just paused it
what he just said like we are
we are the product of people before us
voting and putting in these laws that
didn't think about the future they
thought about yeah what was good for
them right then and there and we
are another product but the benefactors
of what happened way before we came and
so
now it's like
we have we have to think about that and
i feel like a lot of people don't think
about that when they vote and when they
vote on these laws vote on everything
and they just think about right now but
how is a law like this going to affect
someone in 10 years when they're able to
vote it's like the thing is you don't
think about how many consequences come
from a law and there's a lot of
consequences that people don't intend to
happen like the one i gave you earlier
yeah the the law that sounded good right
you even admitted it sounded good yeah
until the consequences these kids think
they're stupid
yeah and it's stuff like that where like
it's like social security sounded good
are you getting social security
no probably not i don't know none of us
are we donate eight percent we basically
donate eight percent of our paychecks
you know that no even social security
it's like um basically they didn't
expect people to live as long as they do
so like when i worked at a job i i was
making like
i was like 50k
or no no no it's not a 401k it goes
towards it's like money that you get
when you're over a certain age from the
government okay yes but people are
living so long like it sounded good oh
okay we'll take money every
like this percent of your paycheck and
when you're old you get it basically but
the problem is people are living longer
and longer and with more and more
medical issues so like we i i would give
up i remember looking at my paycheck and
it was a couple thousand dollars of my
it was like i was making around 50k
and it was eight percent of that so
whatever that's like what 4k
because eight eight out of 100 is eight
so half of that's boring yeah four
thousand dollars
every year
they take out of your paycheck i will
never see it because they're it's gonna
run out like it's not sustainable
what do you mean it's gonna run out like
how is it gonna run off if you don't use
it this is okay this is something my dad
taught me and this this just made me a
conservative i'm just gonna warn you
this is how powerful it is
okay my dad he looks at things as like
he would tell me it's like two dollars
in one dollar out
so when you're looking at a program
you can only have so many programs where
you put two dollars into something
and you make one dollar off of it okay
because it's losing money does that make
sense because you're putting two dollars
and you're taking one dollar out and you
can like while these programs these free
like social programs they sound like
nice like social security welfare all
that stuff you can only have so many
so many before we run out of money
or what do they do they print more money
and what happens the value of the dollar
goes down yeah and that doesn't and then
you have people in the middle class
losing
money that they saved their whole lives
and so it's like there's all these
repercussions about for for things that
sound good and sound nice and it's the
people and like on the screen that'll
say oh i'm helping these people
but you're really taking away the middle
class
because you're taking away like their
money out of their like 50k right i come
from a good family so i i'm in a
different position but let's say i
wasn't let's say
sorry you know
yeah but like like you like they're
taking away that money from you yeah
instead and they're giving it to the
generation before you and you're never
gonna and like four four grand times ten
years and then on top of that the value
of the dollar is going down and the
people making the policies get to say oh
i'm helping people like jess but they're
not helping you
wow
isn't that crazy that's
wow
it red pills you a little bit oh my days
and their pomo professors are quite
annoying which i think is probably i
agree with something else they're not
just annoying like they're destroying
the universities and that's not a good
thing and they're particularly
destroying the social sciences and the
humanities the sciences are safe so far
but not for long because the scientists
in particular are terrible at politics
and the left-wing activists are great at
politics and so they'll win eventually
the national science foundation is
already introducing diversity
requirements for hiring in mathematics
and universities it's like good luck
with that that's not going to work there
are hardly any mathematical geniuses if
you start putting all sorts of arbitrary
restrictions on their hiring you're just
going to not and you're going to end up
not finding the ones that there are so
besides i don't think that's true
actually because if you say there are
very few mathematical genes
well i'm i want next year i'm going to
be a fellow oxford university so i spend
time talking to academics i've talked to
a lot of academics from my book i do
agree with you there is an illiberal
strain that is sweeping through a lot of
universities i don't think it's an
existential threat and i certainly don't
think it is to me the biggest issue in
world politics today it's the one that i
would choose personally what do you
think is the biggest issue i think that
the rise of strongmen authoritarians
around the world is very worrying and
that's one of the reasons i find the
subtitle of your book fascinating
because
it's called an antidote to chaos why
isn't it an antidote to order which you
also say in its excessive manifestations
is bad i've said that
well you can't write a book about
everything no no but you've specifically
chosen antidote to chaos so why is chaos
300 lectures online and i talked plenty
about the pathology of order in those
lectures okay but i'm just saying a fan
of authoritarian strong men that's for
sure well that's good but i do think
that the way that you talk about order
in the book is something that people
will take away from it be specific okay
so let me think um the way that you hold
them real quick
and antidote is something to make
something better right
why is she upset that it's an antidote
to chaos
they get mad over everything i literally
was like an antidote i was like antidote
helps it get better i was like am i do i
not know the correct definition
sometimes they use these big words i'd
be having to think real hard
no the same i've been over here like i
don't want to seem dumb on camera no no
i've listened to a lot of him but when i
first started listening i would have to
google work yeah i'm gonna go home and
be like okay he said this now i know
you talk about natural dominance
hierarchies in lobsters let's get on to
the lobsters because i think that the
the thing that people take away from
that is
male lobsters compete for female
lobsters and that says something about
society now that's that men need to be
dominant in in society because if
lobsters do it then there is something
that we can read about humans from
there's nothing in there wait let me let
me it is book he's he's a social
scientist so he he gives examples that
are like in the book he talks about
lobsters okay okay because they're
they're i forget why and they cut i'm
sorry the comments is gonna roast me
today but it's okay like they're
somewhat similar to humans and the way
their hierarchies are set up like
something okay she talks about it so so
she's saying like oh so you're saying
like we're like like since lobsters do
it we should do it but that's no this is
what the man studies yeah okay i thought
she was just pulling something from thin
air that's always like lobsters you're
gonna lobsters okay it makes sense okay
chapter at all
that suggests that the way that men
should succeed in human hierarchies is a
consequence of the exercise of power
there's not one line in that entire book
that's that claims that because it's not
what i believe
most human hierarchies as i already
pointed out are hierarchies of
competence not power
okay so that's why we don't live in a
patriarchal tyranny and so if you want
to be a successful man then you should
be competent and that will move you up
the hierarchy and that will make you
attractive and for good reason unless
you want an incompetent mate which is
possible and and
and happens but isn't something that i
would recommend people will sometimes
choose an incompetent mate because
they're intimidated by competence and so
they'll settle for someone who they
don't respect because they feel that
they can master them and they won't be
intimidated but it's not a recipe for a
happy life i can tell you that
so there isn't a line in that chapter
that talks about power as as as the
proper means of conducting yourself in
life there's not a line in the book and
there's nothing in anything i've ever
said that suggests that okay no i'm
sorry but it's really important because
people have read this chapter and they
make exactly the argument that you make
and it's a misapprehension
so it's a misapprehension of the book
okay but if so many people are getting
the same misappropriation could it be
there are so many people that are
getting it there's two million people
that have bought the book and there's a
very small handful of people who have a
particular ideological perspective who
enjoy developing that perspective
because it indicates just what sort of
reprehensible individual i am but it has
absolutely nothing to do with what i
wrote or what i've said or what i
believe
i don't believe that our fundamental
hierarchies are based on power i don't
believe that the way that you move up
our hierarchies is as a consequence of
manifesting power it's competence okay
my big problem with the lobsters is that
it's scientifically
bollocks right it's just you cannot read
across from lobster
look at his face
he's like try me [ __ ] he's like all
right bet come at me
of course you can that's why serotonin
works on lobsters but it works in two
different ways so if serotonin makes
lobsters more aggressive it makes you
know it makes them less aggressive right
no that's not right
serotonin makes human beings more
dominant but less aggressive
and the only reason it makes them more
dominant is because they're less
irritable and they're less defensively
aggressive
so it's not bollocks i know my neural
chemistry so if you're going to play
neurochemistry let's go and do it okay
we'll use the antidepressants work on
lobsters yes they do we make a lobster
that's been defeated in a fight more
likely to fight again that's not the
same mechanism that happens the same
humans because they don't get depressed
as the way that humans are i think
you're anthropomorphizing into a
ridiculous degree these are creatures
that urinate out of their faces i think
that uh the fundamental issue among
knowledgeable
animal behaviorists is that
anthropomorphization with animals is
generally the appropriate tactic unless
you have reason to doubt it which is
because there's continuity between us
and animals rather than discontinuity
and the idea that the
anthropomorphization of animals is
inappropriate is something derived from
1950s behaviorism the the highly trained
affective neuroscientists and people who
study motivation and emotion as well as
neurochemistry know perfectly well that
there is biological and behavioral
continuity across the animal kingdom and
way down into the kingdom as well which
is exactly why i chose lobsters to
indicate that there is so much
continuity in the systems that allow us
to estimate a status position
that we share it with creatures that are
a third of a billion years old and the
reason that i made that argument was to
put paid at least into part in part to
the absurd marxist proposition that
hierarchical structures are a secondary
consequence of western civilization and
free market economies which is as
preposterous a perspective as you could
possibly develop about anything
hierarchies are a third of a billion
years old you can't blame them on the
west or men or capitalism and we're
wired for hierarchical perception in
ways that you can hardly possibly
imagine even our ability to rank order a
set of objects seems to be tightly
linked to our ability to assess the
relative status of people in our in our
social uh milieus
do you understand what he just said
a little bit
like do you understand what he's saying
with like hierarchies being natural
kind of so
because basically he's saying like even
lobsters have hierarchies and
hierarchies aren't necessarily a bad
thing
and so like in in our society like
like there's hierarchies in everything
there's hierarchies and looks yeah
there's hierarchies in um
in basketball there's higher like
there's just people that are better and
there's people that are worse okay
and so he's saying like even lobsters
have hierarchies of like competence all
right
don't don't quote me on the lobster
stuff but like you know what i'm saying
so like she's trying to make it seem
like it's oppressive and terrible but
he's saying no it's based on competence
okay does that make sense do you agree
with that or do you disagree
um
some
i would
yes i would agree on